in southwest China at the foot of the
Himalayas one cultures concept of family
has made it notorious their unusual
social customs have branded the most
whoa as practitioners of free love the
most willow their reputation too one
fact they don't believe in traditional
marriage men and women often have
multiple lovers simultaneously like any
young man
our giba dislikes leaving his lovers bed
to return to his mom's house but giba
knows he can't shirk his
responsibilities to his family outsiders
may find it exotic but most well family
life has little to do with romance
because of matrilineal societies keep
farms intact and in the mother's family
each household lives mainly on what it
grows and the more hands the easier to
farming tea nanobot ago the most
important thing is to help your own
family do well go home go to that big
little wood in my family there are nine
people you're getting alive if there are
nine people working hard then it is
really easy you know despite the reputed
promiscuity the most will live by
rigorous rules of love
with so many adult eyes on them young
people find it tough to connect in
private often they find privacy in a
crowd at a community gathering
this festival held each summer honors
the main most whoa deity it was at such
a festival that giba saw Agra addre in a
new light today she was wearing
traditional dress and I said oh when did
you become so pretty so I made a point
to dance with her and then I looked for
every opportunity to talk to her but he
held back not daring to seek an
invitation to Audrey's home no 10 dozen
wood I was outside talking to her and I
said let me in your room and she said if
you can come in then come in was in the
height when I could thought I used my
knife to pry open the door and just when
I was about to open it I woke up her
scary doll
unmasked giba had to go public with his
love for atre he sought an informal
union that the most will call a walking
marriage to get Audra's mother to bless
the bond Jeeva would have to bring gifts
and have friends plead his case I mean
giba is quite a decent person a good man
he respects his elders I look as if I
mean everyone let's agree to this while
their elders debated the couple kept
still in the end Audra's mother welcomed
her daughter's suitor I am satisfied on
all accounts that is it as a mother I
will be supportive of you
ever since Jeeva has been visiting Audra
openly their daughter is three years old
Sheba's content to see her occasionally
often grown most well children have
little contact with their fathers but
they always have homes filled with
family members they can count on